welcome to this video a rapid game 15
minute chess on icc f yo or what from
Sweden okay um let's see can i play
something slightly offbeat against sd-6
maybe with F for something like this I
want to play something different hmm
what about g3 here's this an idea maybe
g3 why not so a little bit of an
unthreatening proach but shouldn't be
that bad I am maybe he wants to play c6
and d5 now it loses a tempo but I you
know he wants to set up like this with
beef with c66 maybe be five late i am ok
spending a move to to make be five more
difficult yeah I'm still flexible with
my center should I I can play with d 4
or with d3 ok shup to g4 hmm yeah I can
just grab the bishops now I guess unless
he wants to lose a temple no he gives me
the bishop pair oh that's nice I'm
taking the bishop pair of course
collette lee and ok yam and this means i
will play with d3 also why not so it's
quite nice d 3 he cannot go D Phi if I'm
controlling the square and my intention
is to go f 40 hour for a 5 is a move
that pretty much gives up hope for
counterplay really be 5 is almost
impossible not to play and I have a nice
player on the on the King side
I'm going f5 g45 that is dangerous I
think age six now is almost no I thought
it was mandatory ok now let's let's grab
space let's grab space ok i can go f6
now 4 for a nice position but question
should i rush things here are that it's
nice anyway he the only real counterplay
possible is d5 and I'm really preventing
that but ok let's let's develop a little
bit more first I don't really see whoa
really I can go g6 now for a pawn sack
but Oh lights it will be dangerous if he
takes it g6 takes takes Knight takes
Queen age 5 night back yeah but I can
also keep it simple here just keep this
wall of pawns in tech and prepare a
little more a little bit more it's
really yeah but if i take p 5 now and he
takes d5 is like a monster square not
grabbing upon you of course I'm putting
the night on this fantastic square yeah
I guess now now g6 should be a should be
nice yeah come on if he goes h 6 i'm all
set for p sacrifices on age 6 so he
grabs so Queen to h5 and Bishop age 34
for a fantastic position right any other
we have their many nice moves but ok
this looks looks very very strong and
the bishop over here asking black what
exactly is your next month you cannot
move the Knights or the bishop or the
rook I don't know the Queen s to protect
e7 it's it's really difficult to move
anything g6
yeah but I go to age 6 I think all this
check on e6 is also nice check Knight
takes Queen takes g6 hmm it looks like
very close to a win
it's very very close that's probably
winning right but how is he defending
after Queen age 6 I really it's really
not possible right I'm just playing King
age to look G 1 and this explodes yeah
there is really no need for any tactics
ok
so just King age two and drooped g1 or
something else yeah I need to look on g1
yeah if I I couldn't really take the
night hangs but I could have taken e7
and their five probably four win but I
really don't think there is just one way
to to finish this off the route coming
to g1 should should decide matters
really um Luke g1 then or can also take
on f5 it's a little bit funny because it
all looks like it wins but maybe this
isn't the case and not almost win even
Bishop f5 looks nice Bishop f5 night f5
rook f5 g cakes root g one check king of
700 crooked g say they all when yeah
it's really nice yeah c'mon let's do it
like that g takes root g one
now this is made now LG takes rook g1
check king of seven group to g7 check
key to e8 Knight f6 check Bishop takes
f6 Queen h5 check 96 greene takes g6
Queen f7 and mate ok he has taken on h4
to avoid the the line I just mentioned
oh ok ok then I just have to take him
check
queen a king here Queen h5 check King e6
Queen takes at five made check
checkmate yeah there was an opening
disaster really we go back here yeah I
don't really like this position already
for Blackie this is a very one-sided
affair he is of course relatively solid
but I have a very straightforward way to
play with our form and this is this gets
dangerous he needs some sort of counter
play or put up a better defense I really
thought age six was necessary something
like this so that age 4 can be answered
with this this is not nice but it has
some some defensive I mean this is this
is a defensive set up that that might
hold for a while after this it gets it
gets really ugly yeah h4 yeah and this
is so yeah trying to somehow get to get
play but it just gives up d5 of course
I'm not taking the porn but entering and
here you have a number of nice options
already Queen h5 is also strong but this
is quite convincing that the toughest is
probably age 6 for the time being but
then I have have things like this in the
mix I mean note that he cannot move any
of those pieces and it's just like it's
play three pieces down almost yeah he
took this is this a lot yeah after g6 I
thought bishop e6 probably already wins
but I wasn't totally sure chat let's
let's have a brief look takes TX this is
check this is winning absolutely sorry
check I wasn't completely sure about
this move but it should win as well
somehow I had this one wins according to
the
engineer stockfish but okay my move is
ok he has no way to get get out of this
anyway here I could have taken with the
bishop but I just prefer to get the
rukon GG farm yeah and now I took for
for the win took him on G takes rook g1
is is deadly it's no way to to continue
him took here root cheeks and Bishop
edge freue if he takes this I'm Jack
Queen h5 Queen age 5 is of course easier
I had seen this mate which are already
active in the chat live commentary check
checkmate formate also quite cute this
is a little bit longer check check check
check mate ok so this is what you tried
and then I can just take it at check
check chadwin it with this check mate
yeah it this is a clear warning that you
should try to get some count to play
against a flank attack against this F 5g
for you should try to go for d 5 or some
sort of counter play here for example
Knight b6 is also move may be intending
d5 at least this is a plan we sound in
some trouble here already but this is at
least trying to try to resist ok hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching